you're all aware of the rule goose beat
by that dog and beef in the car park
coverage car part and please teach off
your mobile phones I started just for
absence but apologies from counselor
butcher counselor sparing substitute
member counts for Western for the
tortilla non members attending this
welcome countless may be right minutes
of the meeting Hills 22nd of May 2018
does everybody agree those
item five declarations of interest
item 6 audit progress report
yeah James quit defer to myself so I'll
take this like to thank you very much
this is my first progress report for
2018-19 and covers a period April to
June 2019 first of all I'd like to point
out progress has been slow I would have
liked again now into an absence of a
border resource we actually are down to
one member of staff again which is
essentially in June we are not taking
actions to remove remedy that situation
we undertook interviews last week for
the vacant post we're going to make a
decision like this week on the
appointment further to that we have two
kids
resources from the Compliance Manager
which going to be working in internal
audit I believe that two days a week to
assist the delivery audit plan for a
period six months so yeah we recognize
there is a lack of resource into an
audience that we are now attempting to
address the situation hopefully that we
would look to deliver they would be
witty plan in 1919 if I can refer
members to 6.5 appendix well
this table essentially provides a time
overdue to work we're completely in the
first quarter of the year the first to
Dominic engagement alone is complete
this is better spree kill these were
actually 1718 audits that we haven't
completed the draft before final report
four in the last period so these are now
finished and reports are being issued
both receive the limits of assurance
rating we'll come back to procurement
later in the session
as a part of a separate item man and
then is it again done we'll talk about
that later tonight
much of the work for the first period
has been concentrated on completing the
Housing Benefit subsidy which is a piece
of work we undertake for external audio
the headline from this piece of workers
is there's been a reduction in volume of
errors identified in comparison to the
last previous plane the results our work
will now be passed of external audit to
consider the results and carry on
further testing this required by a DWP
so enabling to determine the extent and
impact of the errors within the whole
claim and provide their opinion on the
housing benefit subsidy
talking about the two audits we
completed the main issue arising from
the pyramid procurement audit concerned
our failure to comply with our own
contract procedure rules more
importantly non compliance with EU
procurement regulations and that we
should have better thighs the contract
for agency staff in an official European
Journal and we didn't do such regard to
debtors we identify the nominees with
the fact applied to invoices and
inconsistencies in the information
published in relation to fees in
consistent debt recovery processes
adopted for building controls and delays
in progress in housing related debt and
also we we looked at user access
controllers around the data system and
found some problems with that so that's
the information in relation to the two
audits we completed in the first period
of the year I also like to referred
members to appendix 3 which is progress
in relation to audit recommendations at
present there are in the region of 60
live recommendations not all of them are
due currently I think first year do you
buy at the end of the next month we have
to discuss progress in relation to the
recommendations with the leadership team
and we're looking to progress the
outstanding recommendations as soon as
possible with circuit heads quite just
think any cushions
restaurant will be verticals something
else right and firstly the results of
patience I think it's been three four
years this has been an issue and I still
can't believe it's still an issue yeah
and I think we get the same response
each time - dude we're trying to do
something about it but we've never seen
two too many yet a game that we're
looking to a point at yet again I think
that's what frequently happens at least
because we're told that way then surely
nothing happens what's the cost
implications this in I did read it on
our panel across the notes I made this
guy do know that they are covered by the
external it's about the the the fact
that we're all behind the world yeah
does that give us a cost implication
that the external just may have to do
additional workers make up the fact we
haven't managed to keep up to date
ourselves or we might not completing
some aspects of it which means they may
have to look a little bit more depth and
they would otherwise do okay yeah it's
place it affects my my my opinion
basically in my own report is my my
opinion on the counters controlled
environment also was a my take a view on
that lying a report and would look at it
in terms of Batman and I'm able to
provide an opinion on account of control
environment then obviously Ian one would
take a dim view map so we would look to
complete all work in the audit plan and
whatever that means so we might have to
buy in some resource last year I managed
to provide a member of my own team to
basically Grocery Council for a period
four to five months to complete the
audit plan so if we're unable to provide
an opinion on council
then that would have an impact for E&Y
whether you would look to do some work
myself I wouldn't wouldn't also provide
a comment on our inability to basically
deliver our audit plan Chris may want to
add something to say in 2015-16
see the government's always management
Vincent patrols
regulations 2015 define the chemicals
who maintain that
[Music]
and I mean the Patriots oh yeah how
close are we to that are you happy are
usually that we're not in danger of that
at this moment in time well hopefully
when we applied for the vacant place and
also we have that additional resource
provided by compliance that we will
deliver Lee what it claimed as set out
in learning regional plan with proper
sense this committee so hopefully
learning the first quarter ends of the
year so hopefully we can plug the gamble
or backfill the lack of resource the
hope is we will deliver you a new plan
that sets out if we run into additional
problems than we will bring that back to
this community that present word of
first quarter through the air and
hopefully we'll fill it over to resource
if you may end up actually to deliver
the plan we might apply an additional
resource over and above the post and
there two days from front of clients day
so yeah we would take a look at it later
in the air and make a decision as to
whether we have to buy an additional
resource over thump the in between well
improvements remain but I would like to
find out that it's an issue for all
local authorities of this side it's not
the disrupter council uncommon
experience the same problems at Basel
new council it's the issue around small
council's is one or two stars if someone
leaves or go sick and then presents a
major problem for counselors of this
size one of the things our table that
they're six would occur is you know
there is perhaps a need for an order
consortio where we get back tests to a
larger portal resources having such a
small team puts you in a difficult
position as soon as someone leaves for
go sick and then you have
make a decision whether to buy in
additional resource a significant cost
because this is about 400 pounds of a
plaster it's not going to get many audio
days of that amount of mining so prefer
to just essentially recruited that post
but just it's a Carol absolutely agree
funded perhaps is time to because we
can't be the only Authority having this
problem locally so perhaps the idea of
the consortium to provide that service
is the way we should go because this has
been going on for a number of years and
I from looking at I don't think you you
might appoint for then placed and what
go and I should master-wife addendum
you've rated everyone have been planning
for too big and they wouldn't act a bit
more expensive there is a current
problem that Anna
Fighting's seen it what it says yeah
because I think it's it might be there
like we've got marina don't work for
like forgotten bar thing lots and lots
of scene witnesses the top end the cream
if you like tend to drift towards London
so he's trying to attract those
individuals to Council of science of
Roger so I think he's like necessary to
to grow your own scarce and faster than
what we're looking to do is reinvigorate
a training auditor program because we
recognize that I can't attract senior
auditors because London's on my doorstep
and I can't pay the 48 hours and they
want for a senior decide so we are
looking to reinvigorate a trainee or to
the program and it's
where you had to start now you have to
start at the ground dry your own instant
most auditory we as a council would have
trouble doing that if it was about I'm
sure you want to do the work penetrate
and staff would be quite a blip them
here making something I'm looking with
other local authorities they see we can
share the training I found a train you
what surrounds and local for it so
you're sharing a boat no I'll do that
the obvious I'll revisit this that's
meeting probably I just need to move on
to the other well either quite a bit I'm
concerned about debtors but yet it
appears that that's been addressed I
wanna see what happened from work on
offer that for the next meeting the one
thing I was really gonna raise on this
bond was serving it's a small point
perhaps but it's about the status of
that in charging for provision of waste
and recycling bins it looks like a
possibly charge charging I think they're
not a lot of time a policy it's not a
normal business activity so they
shouldn't be charged it's my
understanding now this perhaps is a
small point but it also relates to
report later on where perhaps we don't
get tax advice soon enough is this a
question that perhaps we're not you know
so this is one area where we may may be
doing something with regard to advantage
of being picked up later an orbit is
there is there over arching proper than
we may not
getting tax advice in areas soon enough
because we might be worried about budget
afraid it's I'm just wondering if
there's something things going on which
we're missing because we're a bit scared
of getting the proper advice yeah so we
subscribe to a local government tax
advice tax and that is a dedicated
blowing the wicked call any tax however
saying that way again with the resources
that we have we recognized that this is
a bit of a weakness we didn't the wider
finance team so the process of
looking as suitable try me for the
finance business call and say
again if you like two or three people
who were trained up as what you would
call super users whilst that's difficult
within us to have that expert knowledge
but go to if you like other than PS tax
that go to within the council which
stuff you've got knowledge around the
wider reality issues it is a very
specialist area as you are aware and not
everyone that there's a bit of a a
general thought process that if you work
in finance you should happen with an
expert knowledge of the idea where
that's not the case so we are we are
addressing it it has come out in some
some units behind the data solve it as
well so it's an area that we are
addressing the I really embrace social
scene as we speak
nice core system
of course it's possible to get healthy
checks I'm sure anteaters before that if
we needed it
why should we be expensive but it could
be cost-effective in the longer term in
the fact that we could want to find
penalties and fines if we do something I
don't think we wouldn't like to take
specialist advice on every single and
sort of area that we try to be a deal
necessarily sales mastered the the
principles to get our business partner
team trained up to reasonable level so
they at least know when the right
questions are to ask and where they need
to get that specialist advice that's the
intention but I think what the point I'm
trying to make is though they probably
happen when something changes or we do
something new are they also going to be
reviewing so much then what we do now
because it may be being done wrong in
debtors particularly where the eighties
oh I didn't ask yet
I think the exam will yes we get the
retrospectively to revise areas and
change their password
thank you updates on citizen quitter
excuse me yeah well points we'll be
talking about the someone's completely
uh not to be confused as homeboy was
talked about I mean it seemed to one way
to go conversation and I couldn't follow
anything brother they were talking on
the notes it was it referred to if I
make Gerald it referred to 6.22 yeah but
then he mainly w80
played on Warnock plain but we did was
actually very abstract aa claim but as
it was a long business asset which could
be referred to mean that it's something
we please not or his ass on the sky boys
and trying to want to be a team thank
you that was the area talk about then on
if I may through the chair then there
was our you're right discussion around
that way how much the possibility of
other areas of the aiib in wrong got any
weed on the conversation thank you
right guess right thank you so it's this
is more about an overarching comment on
the report counseling away in his
initial question asked for how much is
this costing or potentially costing with
the shortfall in resources etc you did
mention a possibility of four hundred
pounds a day that's the only figure we
have we don't have anything what are the
things that I'm noticing at a little bit
at the moment we're getting up a lot of
referrals to costs etc but no fears in
some of the items that we've actually
got in the Republic I think as we are
going forward as a council war none that
we've got some pretty substantial
problems coming up
it would help us if you could in going
forward when we actually see these
problems if you could at least give us
an idea what the costs are going to baby
let me give you an idea they things like
this is a small item but this this is a
an idea one your six point sixteen and
6417 just talking about the Fourth
Movement line policy procedure we were
additionally outside this committee
forwarded the Environmental Health
Service plan which tells us that there
would be fees charged for checking
restaurants etc which would cover the
cost of whatever the administration is
but we don't know what the
administration is which we should know
because is it going to just a letter or
is it going to you're personally going
and checking it actually indicates then
the level of service that we are going
to be offering our residents with
regards to what kind
the things we're going to be checking if
it's just going to be very simple and
it's not going to say for instance the
amount of money that we're going to
raise on fees there is 500 pounds of
gear I would venture to suggest that our
amounts of effectiveness we can be on
that we love on that particular issue is
5,000 pounds a year and we're looking to
have officers actually available for
that that gives us a bit more
reassurance as to what's happening so it
is just a request that as we're going
forward we could have a little bit more
financial tank to some of the comments
that are actually coming through it's
not not criticism but I am aware that we
are coming up to some difficult times so
it could be open to questions
perhaps some points sorry
if you want now you never know if it's a
general kind of question housing
benefits reward what is the relationship
with the department worker pensions do
we actually lose money through housing
benefit fraud or is there a recompense
that comes from the department work
depending on the nature of the four
identified and we might be responsible
not being up
it could be some impact on
if it's a job you know the payment we've
identified in this process of
that's once then he broke a match one
yes that's under has been fit wheels
tonight so we could take that away and
found I think it will depend on the
individual circumstances and the nature
of thank you in there's a lot of
implementation dates that either past or
the end of this month
any comments on that is great this is
something we have taken to a leadership
team and they're going to raise it with
managers in terms of progress and
outstanding recommendation so has been
identified as an issue and it's
something that we discuss with the
leadership to internally help we show
recommendations or action so it's
something that's been discussed with
leadership Tina how they can ensure that
their men service upon management and
implementing recommendations in their
timely fashion there's a lot of already
being called back and it appears that
we're not getting any further forward on
a little design it's something we've
recognized we have taken taken up work
with senior management to
right
something's with ICT oh yes
page six point one for number seventeen
of that report seventy the middle
paragraph on the right take your new
system administrator group with first
meeting scheduling made will includes an
action point arising to be included into
energy like meeting the July meeting
that didn't take place it's now Cheryl
for the second week in August and is on
the agenda already to be taking on to
that one so we'll be checking that one
up backends and rules to make see what's
happened
it doesn't say I'm very good that so
many stuff is being put back
[Music]
okay
will we see an improvement on this over
the next few months I certainly hope so
that's one reason we did we did flag it
so it's been portable to be obtained to
ensure that we only raise recommendation
but we think there's a good reason to do
so and I shouldn't get the priority that
we
consistory had tended to halogen 60 we
could begin to type at the end
I was told I'd be taken as part of this
and yeah we've published rest after
addendum today the main item on the
agenda tonight and that was to think a
particular point which we praised as
part of the return rajion procurements
so as part of the value to money
conclusion that sandwiches to make they
obviously make some inquiries including
as we've been discussed earlier on and
about the progress of internal audits
that being Hideout of the course of the
year and as we mentioned earlier the
procurement order had been finalized by
the point at which we had on the annual
government statements and so as a result
of the further work that was carried out
and we make we and delve into the detail
of that procurement order to fit in a
bit more detail and it was recognized at
that pointer that had actually been an
unintentional breach of the procurement
regulations in relation to some agency
spend that we'd incurred over the past
couple of years so as a result of that
we're flagging this issue specifically
with audit committee so that you're
aware that this breach has occurred but
as I say
monitoring officer advice and
encouragement myself we both arrived at
the conclusion that as the breach was
unintentional and was driven as he's
mentioned earlier in terms of resourcing
difficulties in the planning department
we thought that this was the most
appropriate forum to raise the issue and
we have a recognized a few additional
actions are going to be undertaken in
addition to what's be putting that in
their main current report that's be
discussed earlier so just start line the
additional actions that we have agreed
to undertake as a council we're going to
prioritize and some additional training
around the current regulation so that
all officers are aware of both iron
inside our own procurement rules and
also e-procurement rules so that the
special understanding of where those
potential creatures that occur we've
also identified a single point of
contact within the HR department and
we'll have some oversight of agency
spends a whole across the organization's
so that we don't unintentionally run
into this issue again and thirdly we are
looking at formal reporting and warnings
of any procurement breaches that could
be about to occur in future so we'll
have place and monitoring of of where
where those potential breaches could
occur in future and we are investigating
with our own system focal point which is
used to them raise orders can be back
these guys helped us identify away a lot
of potential issues in the future and
the fifth point just tonight is that we
have now terminated the agency agreement
also not the agreement but the
particular members of staff that have
been employed onto that agreement to
prevent a further breach occurring in
relation to that particular in that
particular contract and we will look at
our arrangements for queuing agencies
not in future to ensure that this
doesn't happen again so yeah as I said
we've identified there's additional
actions ivan above what was included in
the original internal audit report
although it should be recognized that
training was a was a issue that was
raised was possibly internal bit and
well it was bitching and taking so I'm
happy to take any questions if anyone
that's very how much was the husband and
so their procurement and the procurement
limit is around 180 thousand pounds over
48 month period so that's obviously four
years and I think the title meant was
there was just so much yeah about about
220 so yeah it was it there was a breach
in terms of but as I say it was now an
aggregated it wasn't it an aggregation
level has spent over a prolonged period
of time it wasn't just you know one
instance that led to that bridge as if
that's all noted then members and then
we go to the recommendations was
meteorology that based on delivering the
2018-19 audit plan be noted that the
conclusions and results from the
completely to audit statements in
appendix to be noted and that the
updated stainless of audit
recommendations in appendix 3 be noted
great
chattering noting you didn't item 60 yes
item seven financial statements to
consider to report the detection one
five one okay sir presenting the
operative report 2017 to 18 for members
approval I will just make a few comments
and starts about their financial
statements and then I will hand over to
qa/qc and who will run through an egg
whites and auditors opinion in a bit
more detail so members should be aware
that the draft accounts were published
at the end of May and since then we
entered into two-month audit period
where we've engaged with our external
auditors who come in and check the
validity of our assumptions and our
workings to ensure that the accounts
presented to you of our financial
position at the end of 1718 and to the
public so you I have now substantially
completed their audit work or 1780 and
I'm pleased to say that they have
confirmed that they expect to issue an
unqualified opinion on our accounts
which means that I haven't found any
matter service enough nature towards
them concluding that there are accounts
on presenting uttering fair
in addition to that they also concluded
that they move mass of substance report
and the council's arrangements or not
value for money opinion in terms of
asset during economy efficiency and
effectiveness analysis so I call that's
a really positive conclusion in terms of
our financial statements and I would add
to that that this is the first year that
we have had to work to significantly
shorter and statutory deadlines so in
prior years we've had an additional two
months and so we had an additional month
to prepare the accounts and in an
additional month for the auditors to
come in and do their work and so
previously this would have been reported
around September time in this case we've
met our deadline of publishing our draft
counts by the end of May and we're on
track to say to have that some final
sign or diversion by the end of this
month
so yeah as I say the shorter deadlines
have been challenging process and
authority we have a limited amount of
resource and we perfect we are heavily
reliant on one key person that this
court directs the finance team to
deliver those accounts so and it hasn't
necessarily been an easy process but we
have works quite effectively with our
external auditors to ensure that a lot
of work be done actually prior to the
year-end so we did a lot of work where
we could walk before the start before
the end Hispanic year there's just a
couple of other key points to note so
when we agreed the budget in February we
integrated the level of general balance
were expecting to have a year-end and
the night equated to about 10 percent of
our net revenue budget and following the
divine order of the accounts that move
very slightly upwards so the level of
the general fund balance that we
presenting the accounts year-end it's
nine hundred and eighty nine thousand
pounds which now equates to eleven
percent of our soft in budget for 1819
and in addition I just want to plug that
the annual government statement we
referred to earlier was presented to
objectivity at the last committee
meeting they haven't substantially
changed but there has been some changes
and additions made in conjunction with
our discussions with the ey in
particular we have black now some of the
issues we've spoke about in the earlier
report in relation to the debtors and
procurements order and the spirit issue
that I just spoke to earlier
so I brought a very positive opinion in
terms of our accounts there have been
some adjusted differences in the
accounts compared to the draft position
we reported at the end of May
I'll let Chris ran through some buyers
in slightly more detail but there have
been a number of things where we have
had to make changes to the accounts some
of those are out of our control
I'll get the example of the pensions
funds which was where we were given
addiction figures by our actuary earlier
in the year and at the last minute they
revised their estimates which meant we
had to actually reflect those in our
accounts and there are a couple of other
things where we recognized that the the
costs that we've put into the accounts
was not quite right whatever reason so
everybody example of the community
assets which we had valued at client
leaves value instead of historic costs
which the example where in conjunction
with the orders we've agreed that's not
the correct treatment so we've gone back
and revise that and have some
flexibility in the accounts but overall
there's no adjustments that have been
identified by the auditors where they
know that there's something that needs
changing which we haven't reflected in
accounts so we've made all the
adjustments to accounts we feel
necessary to present that room
to you and the final thing I was saying
relation to the value-for-money Antonia
said you I've indicated they're happy
that we are offering values of money for
our residents and they have liked a
couple of key risks but it had been a
legit work firstly the level of savings
that we have to make as a council and
juicy balanced budget in future years
they recognize that we've got robust
procedures in place for our budget
planning but that the level of savings
we've identified for the medium-term
aren't quite sufficient at this point to
see our balanced budget in the next two
to three years so we recognize there is
further work that needs to be done
around that but they also recognize we
have got sufficient level of reserves
now to provide some assurance that we
are able to we're in a robust position
to be able to deal with that challenge
and the second point they specifically
raised is around green gateway in the
governance arrangements and how we make
decisions around then our training
company again I thought they completed
that there's no significant risk in
terms of our presenter date but there at
there are some underlying risks in terms
of how we make decisions them at what
point we take financial advice and I
think some of those issues have been
added in the meetings we've had
previously so we were obviously taken
board or just advice in terms of how we
make decisions in future
and amid some of their recommendations
so that's all I was going to say and I
will hand over to Chris give you his
view yes it's a lot of documents but I
was going to take you through the key
pages
okay I think to the first assertive
thing to say is that we down from
service somehow study matters in our
water we've now completed our procedures
as Naomi said we were able to give up
on the financial statements the
council's arrangements for becoming an
efficacy and they're using resources so
that is positive news for the council
as Naomi says it's been a good working
relationship with finance team and
ourselves in the work that we did
earlier in the year the corporation
received by US team
and also in Italy quite an intensive
period of three or four weeks which our
conclusions as well so it's a great
great
so in terms of the key areas I just pick
retention if I can truly go to the
[Applause]
so I started thinking best thing is just
to give you a flavor to the context to
the area of its time went through its
the areas of episodic focus that we keep
that we focus on and that's two
softly I just want to go through these
in multiplayer why these areas and
exactly sir
there's something significant biscuits
off the stage please approve error
Kayson don't want these key areas of
focus this this page is common to all
councils it's dealing with the
recognition that enlargements are in
control of the systems and processes
they deal with let's go there for era
and councils we provide all the tests to
try and see whether that any any errors
have occurred so these are the sets out
that page will be absolutely actually do
whatever didn't come out as what
referred to in terms of its application
comes to the expenditure which should
have been classified as revenue
expenditure in terms of the
contracts for services that's the error
that would
your financial statements if you will we
get some some conversations
in terms of the next key area focus next
page student evaluation of property
plant and equipment this is a
significant amount of sum of money you
can be in the accounts estimates that
arise from management experts of the
council between the body were able to
take procedures to see where that
estimate that's made is correct or you
know it was a reasonable assessment that
I made in terms of the lights was here
that we we considered this is where the
areas in terms of the
that's community assets that the council
owned
accounts and they froze to the counter a
third balance sheet you might know
yourself
we compare expenditures statements
and also at the Chatsworth
they should be for you
Council Speaker
[Music]
on the next page this is seven points in
all this deals with patient modules
about hydration in the financial
statements numbered pages to do with the
benefits pension liability and we have
procedures to those groups we are
reliant on the all in terms of the
County Council or something
attention from and it was there that was
where the difference in guesstimate was
found
the movement opening the city
but this is not have any effect
counsel I'm starting this year affected
all counsels of ethics
it was the issue boss of the castle and
it's bad impression correctly which is
supposed to be
the difference between my estimates my
I'm always about the actual movie
at last area of focus which is sunset
1.7.5 is business rates use process this
is where there's a provision in the
accounts for potential appeals against
the business to be reasonable but this
year it was taken house so we look to
calculations produced by the counseling
to see what procedures they they adopted
what it was
so those are the five key areas of all
it focus that we traced our I think the
further up its agreed the capital e
prenatal trading company this is a seven
foot six
this is quite important because the
council is now preparing group accounts
because this is a this is a wholly owned
subsidiary of the Council of doom and
crowns races work first time this year
the councillors altered those accounts
into its over the cat's the issue for
was there is the consolidation process
of bringing those accounts in to
council account and that was pretty cool
and to say they're just important
so I can move on I think the next large
area is the body for money conclusion
to reached this
there are two areas of risks regarding
money first once we understand that she
versus aliens the main concern and they
I recently set out there the issues that
we said we would be addressing which was
looking in a savings plans with me
counsel
budget gap and Webern of savings plans
the most daily or 1890 and the savings
concepts and savings plans that work
identified and I'll try to be brief with
success during the year which is the
future savings plans where some concepts
of the others mostly to work
[Music]
in terms of the second risk that we had
I'm sorry before I go on about I just
want to point out the graph
which is on page three this graphic is
our assessment of property position
where the council's reserves would be
one based on the noise that we cover the
first time what he's trying to do is to
say what the reserves because the
council got now and is ain't going
through a series of steps to say what
the sources position would look like at
the end of the process and then compare
that to the minimum level of reserves
that section or by water feels is
necessary to maintain
we start off at that point war three
that we believe considers and then we we
take account of the
I'm spending on budgets that the council
has achieved
then we take account obviously that's
use of reserves of extra years to see
whether the use of reserves research
that we have be replanted depleting the
stock in fact what we saw have some
surplus reserves next obvious to deal
with the reserves needed if statement
plans aren't achieved based on the last
three years
not all same as the achieve
and then all that
below the line at 40,000 degrees think
the situation there but if you don't you
lose your savings you may have to draw
deserves the three point five seven
billion refers to the fact that there
its funding the camera sees which is not
assertive and this is the recycling
background that the council receives
basics County Council and also gas tax
sharing it's a lot take your order to
get there that these are about 17 pounds
it says now forecast and that is
unthinkable
in position
the issue is that clearly sir should not
support widgets
in that specific purpose and that's why
we stressed how important our
innovations in order to achieve the
savings plans
so yeah this is football I fish a bunch
of money
just by area study
they'd next stage next section with the
second significant risk that we had on I
think money was to do with the local
training comes need feedback gateway
training development limited which was
the complete that was set up or intended
to be used to derive income through
promise management in that area we noted
three course that we all members and we
also noted that it's possible to counsel
financial schemes likes to deal with we
noted there is also those reports
the reports indicated that
I've inserted commercial solutions
optimistic and that led to the council
rephrasing house of characters to
progress its housing projects we looked
at this we probably slightly procedures
on this because this was an issue for us
in terms of
and the council will be achieving
running correctly the results
so we took some tests and we concluded
that the overall impact was insufficient
for us to qualify the
I've included
relation to this element but we have
made recommendations that if it's cool
or this is a setting answer in terms of
project management complex types of
projects the time frames are went to get
get specialist advice duty it's at the
time we need the president
[Music]
I think I couldn't come into the best
quite quickly because we don't talk
about the rangecontrol apartments issue
to be a record that was various about
that procurement but on page seven point
one is that's out it's too large but
this shows basically the activity on
journalists out the year they sharing
journals and importantly because they
count and scope that test that we do in
terms of this possibility
the state we have is quite useful to us
the key item to the top two perhaps by
no system my volume on your system by
value so that money of journals journals
who were taken by staff directly is as
low in the number of the values
concerning high that's an area for focus
our work
that piece indication of the amount of
money
we put aside
this is the area that we threw guessing
for information that we hope to provide
management rental conventional insights
into you
activity on the counts see it whether
its mind expectations
finally I think I just need to draw your
attention to the appendices which talk
about our independence
there's no distress and it's official
attention
I've set out a table all you please just
say that there will be an extra charge
this year rule
various addresses which I surprised
and section C deals with less
representation
thank you any questions from anybody
that's irrelevant at first everyone and
you know not many where the
recommendations will be made on medical
money can they be permanently attached
the appropriate committee chairmen and
offices paying for family for money for
great weight weight development would be
the investment presumably so it has a
being done was that being done so we've
had an initial audit feedback with the
managing director so he's aware of the
profits of this report and it's funny
being finalized in the last week or so
so we haven't had the opportunity to
feedback to the relevant boards yet but
as I said we're looking to take all the
recommendations made in the report so at
the next important opportunity we will
base the issues and most appropriate of
Japan
so that will be raised the neutral base
before when the news reporters yes will
ever look to weed them into the existing
reports are going or we can add an
interceptor an agenda item witness sorry
there was a specific question during
this twelve seven one three nine I think
I understand it this is the better
angels with the century house in fact
recoverability
whether counsel are Road I understand
350 over there offenders coming to the
Council of three hundred one thousand
one hundred ninety pounds I've decided
so she's vit which is recoverable by
central working does and which it and
that's a propulsion it then would pay to
the council however reading this I'm not
sure because I was quite stunned to read
here that we seem to not be able to find
the agreement we have to be the same
treatment regarding this amount so is
this amount do sanitary agree that they
owe the council 350 1992 pounds or would
there be any issues as we seem unable to
find the agreement and also by the fact
that doesn't appear to be the
arrangement the photo GRC either
so the amount it's not under dispute
sanctuary and knowledge that its own it
just has a visit maybe paid for some
cash returns at year-end you're right
that it's in a stroke treatment over ten
years ago at which point in the housing
stock was transferred to sanctuary and
unfortunately yeah the records haven't
been maintained in their fall on either
side so there's a as you say that we
have got something records in terms of
the actual agreement that was put in
place at that time however secretary
have had the amounted by their own
auditors and they they concluded that
the the amount that was owing to acid is
their value so to say that's not on in
front of dispute and we are going to
take on state rather than work this year
to try and uncover the full set of
records that relate to those
transactions there is a higher amount
than we've had in previous years which
is why it's been sort of like dominant
in the audit report this year and
although we haven't brought specific
records around a trauma HMRC agreement
and there is is a knowledge that there
are and similar schemes in place HMRC
have agreed to so it's enough it is a
being a widely acknowledged being that
is in place because the number of
authorities it's not a unique
circumstance it's just we don't have the
actual exact circumstances relating to
our individual green secretary to hands
at this point that I say we're looking
to try
and also we've got more shorts but for
the next year but we haven't by any
concerns about actually paying the money
of hospitals I say they've agreed to and
it's an oddity they just haven't is any
notification you don't need to do a
little curry interest because of on-site
treatment
because it's big and if I can just find
your coupler sort of general comments
and thank everybody involved the amount
of work has gone into this because it's
it's no mean feat to have two whole
months takeoff timeframe for doing this
work was complex of this and when you
look through the report and see the the
various aspects of the council's
operation that have been looked into in
detail it's a significant piece of work
for everyone involved the council is a
complex organization with its its
fingers in lots of different pies the
walls we looked at and this level of t
detail is no meaning feed the sometimes
a couple of things that sort of
frustrate me about already because we've
got here a report that's that's good
reflects that the council is is doing
its work well there's one or two little
breach that we need to make as we go a
lot of that certainly being expected but
when it's just the term on qualified
accountants that's used it I think it it
doesn't do justice to what goes into it
with the background environment that
we've been working in over the last few
years I am really pleased that were in
the position were in and without wanting
to sound flippant when you talk about
the future budget planning and the
challenges that are heard tell us
company we don't know it's a there's a
lot of work it's not just for us that's
for all Council so thank you very much
you put the question
we were picked on page seven point three
of the recommendation
it is proposal committee result that the
financial statements be approved and
signed by the chairman of the Audit
Committee and at the movement in general
fund balances be noted three
item 8 external audit 20,000 and 18 to
19 feet consider the report of the
section 1.1 a hostage server
presenting the external audits 2018-19
feed letter so yeah this is an advising
this for me what I am about the level of
please I expect so empowering their
audit work for this financial year 1890
at that point to note and we have
prepared a separate auditor for our
Housing Benefit clubs became work in
1890 and we prepared that Firebug
Urban's framework agreement with BDO and
we have a absolute information whenever
the police in relation to that work yet
so that will be brought back to audit
committee able to offer more information
after that so this is just in relation
to the Corbett words that you I will be
paying out so the poor the the audit
work and it's supposed to be down to six
thousand six hundred ninety eighty why
the audit fees are sacked is that
there's a national body the public
section order appointments that
negotiates lead levels on behalf of all
councils and they negotiated a fee
reduction of 23% from seventeen eighteen
which is positive news
and rustling all capsules just point out
relation to the work that's been carried
out for 1718 that is obviously subject
to scale fee variations if this
additional work that you're just have to
undertake so that may not be the final
fear that's levied on us but that that's
the indicative call fee that will be
charged to us for the main leader
question so yeah it's really just for 90
minutes and at this stage it is proposed
that limited razones that the annual
board it to the twenty thousand eighteen
to nineteen fee
better be noted local government audit
committee briefing to vote external
auditors or making a breathing through
provide every possible within
[Music]
I
and
and cancel it buddy thank you well thank
you for this quite interesting people
it explains a few questions you don't
mind I'll do quite like little bit of
the back key questions for all the
committee's you'll be missing Oh guess
what I do know actually one of the ones
which has come up recently it's gender
pay equality nah no though because we
probably under where we are on 250
employees assume we do not have to be a
kind of ripple that voluntary voluntary
basis first fish look like tomorrow's is
it easy I don't know if it's costly to
do or is easily available so is he
saying and it's actually and all
optimizations has been recently maybe
and that employee I have hundreds of
employees has been required to report
and legend to pay doubt but because
Scott Schmidt and horse to load up a
shark we know statutorily obliged to
report on that however fairly recently
in the last couple of years we did
products an Equal Pay object and we have
got some information on the gender pay
gap at that time so that is potentially
something that the committee and who to
request that we refreshing if you would
like to see that information in terms of
court headlines of where we are at that
time we were broadly comparable and in
terms of I doing the pay gap with the
wider economy and so so the gender gap
wasn't massively out of line with with
where I thought authorities were at that
time but as I say we have got
information that we can
makes available and we can we can
potentially refreshen when we did look
at that and within the last year on what
motion to request that please Jim so he
could offer a motion to request that we
ask the information on the base of
people should not be too costly in time
or money to do what I just said I think
that the world me I probably have cost
associated with that but it isn't it you
know yeah yeah it's about that that
that's an appropriate you know something
that you requested then we we can do
that so second of the motion sorry on
gender pay equality it's not a stacked
requirement because we have fewer than
250 employees average work has been done
on it a few years ago but I they
probably wouldn't be too costly to
provide that information and I think
given that
the current problems of gender equality
pay I think it would be good for this
council to know where we are on it so
the proposal was that we could if we if
they information have come to this
committee as long as it wasn't and
that's quite willing but not too costly
in time or money to provide that
information so is there a seconder for
the mention a little bit if I could
continue the the next week was about him
making tax the digital but obviously
that's about education which cannot be
like when 2019 and I thought it was
quite interesting to find in here and I
just wanted help and we are for that I
could take out my chest so yeah we we
are aware of what's going to be
happening next year we have already had
discussions with our finance software
provider they are busily writing a
module for us to be able to use which
will allow us to call the VA team
or straight out the system which
right again
and just a final one within within this
I thought was interesting was about lis
have have we done any checks or with an
internal audit haven't done anything to
check that we are compliant with the
mess with national minimum wage I know
some councils will hold up on this it's
not a piece of work we have undertaken
and at least I'd advice from our HR lead
and obviously we need our high scales in
line with the national pay scales for
2018 and they've both been designed to
actually fly imagine a living wage was
very national minimum wages to say for
this one actually a so an aviation in
there so we are we tend to make
deductions before uniforms and things
like that which could kind of matter we
do do but that's not asking that because
obviously a lot of them for a fair of it
by making deductions
yeah I'm looking more for uniforms or
for something else have party well it's
a like sporty meaning for international
pay and scales like that so yeah we've
didn't know where my nan Batian place I
can't even thank you
and just the general question what's
happening with the retention of business
rates the proportion that councils are
being allowed to retain
that one so yeah the business rates
retention scheme as you say is currently
being looked at by a central government
with the intention that the scheme will
be reset at 2021 so we're not expecting
any changes coming scores from next
financial year which is the budget
setting process we're looking at the
moment but they are government are
consulting on a number of changes which
could potentially making that impact and
authorities in terms of the by
percentages of business rates we get to
retain and also the sort of level of
their portal pops and tasks and how
they're fun things to be distributed
with between local authorities and so
that is an area we're keeping a keen
element we will obviously report back as
soon as we know more to to members on on
what that that potentially look like so
Jim there's just one more tour mr. Xu's
at the beginning of Molly's tonight I
can't write in too soon it's just around
the the how is the exactly effect sort
of it how is the effective effectiveness
of your order all the committee assess
and Molly to it which I found another
interesting question to ask and I
suppose this goes hands hands with
training which was just bone but it'll
be in the autumn now but also I was
reading this about the Olympic Committee
effective is effectiveness is one from
would talk it they talk about
no we have spoken with Ernst & Young
about oh I'm not saying we do do it I
didn't know if we've had discussions
around that I'm quite a bit to take take
that yeah it's my fault the training
wasn't delivered
that's it so we appreciate your full
body also I can just explain how it
worked at Basner and council president
council they would have community
undertakes a self-assessment we use the
toolkit and then the team and produces a
report which is taken to a full council
on its perceived effectiveness so
basically the challenge it's brought to
two councils that difficulty so it's
essentially a self-assessment we're
gonna report produced by chairman it's
something that we can put two members
and turns actually is that something
they like to it we'd like to see is
something that's commented on on our
external assessment of winter an audio
what we should put that to committee
members whether that's something they
would like to do something their report
they would like to write on the work of
the committee during during the beyond
18 19 so something we can look out and
help how it would look
is that possible chairman - without go
on to that it potentially for the next
meeting we can either bring to to a
committee meeting or discuss the need
for such during dinner training session
in automating Charlie - to go through
the chairman
the yeah I can okay like a broom and
item on what he effectiveness to the
next community
because would try to solve our customer
sequester to the standards picture as
well as X training I'm not sure how that
worked there for fighting guys for the
status which you know I think German if
you're happy that this committee takes a
view on whether it would like to follow
through along the lines the mr. Porter's
mentioned it would probably be the right
forum for that because it's the
committee making that decision that's
that's that's thinking
so if the committee are in agreement
with that they're all boring the next
wave read here we'll be thanking
yeah Varian further questions on any
matters well thank you very much closing
meeting 2022